قبل لحظات فقط، اضطرت فرق CNN على
الأرض بالقرب من حدود إسرائيل وغزة
إلى الاحتماء والقفز في خندق، نعم
بسبب ما كان يحدث في السماء، سأريكم
هذه
اللحظات، استمعوا إلى هذا
انزلوا قريبًا،
اقتربوا قريبًا
أغلق أنت بخير أنت بخير أنت بخير أنت
بخير أنت بخير أنت بخير أنت بخير أنت بخير أنت بخير أنت بخير حسنًا هذه هي
المكواة حسنًا هذا  مكواة
كلاريسا على الأرض الآن،
كلاريسا تخبرنا بما يحدث، قف بجانبك، مرحبًا
جون، سامحني،
موقفي غير أنيق بعض الشيء ولكن لدينا للتو
وابل هائل من الصواريخ القادمة إلى
هنا، ليس بعيدًا جدًا عنا، لذلك
اضطررنا إلى ذلك  احتمي هنا على جانب الطريق
نحن على بعد حوالي خمس دقائق فقط غزة
في هذا الاتجاه يمكننا الآن سماع
الكثير من الطائرات أه في السماء يمكننا أيضًا
سماع القبة الحديدية وهي
تعترض أه عدد من تلك
الصواريخ بينما كانت تحلق في السماء
وإحداث تأثير في هذا الاتجاه أه
ليس بعيدًا جدًا من هنا وصلنا إلى هذا
الموقع لأن هذا كان نقطة الصفر أه
بالنسبة لهذه العملية الكاملة للمذبحة
جاء مقاتلو حماس أه على
شاحنة صغيرة وكان هذا هو المكان الأول الذي
اخترقوا فيه الجدار الحدودي وقاموا  لقد
قادنا بشكل أساسي إلى أسفل هذا الشريط فقط
رشنا الرصاص أينما ذهبوا
ورأينا في الواقع أنني كنت أمسك به
قبل أن يحدث ذلك وكان علينا أن نصل إلى
سطح السفينة ولكن الأسلحة الثقيلة
المستخدمة تقول إنه يمكننا النهوض الآن
أم إلى أين نتجه إلى آسف
ثانية واحدة فقط يا رفاق، حسنًا، لنصعد ونذهب من
هذا الاتجاه وبعد ذلك حسنًا، حسنًا، الآن يمكنني أن
أريكم آه المشهد هنا، هذا هو المكان الذي
جاء فيه هؤلاء المسلحون لأول مرة وفتحوا
النار على كل هذه المركبات آه هناك
عربة أطفال بالأسفل هناك مقلوبة
جانبها يمكنك أن ترى هناك كلايتون
إذا أظهرت فقط على مسافة هناك
نوع من الضربات يبدو كما لو كان في غزة
أيضًا أه رد إطلاق
النار أم أن الدخان الناتج عن
إطلاق الصواريخ سامحني أم أنه
صعب بعض الشيء بعد أن كنت جاثمًا في
لا تعرف بالضبط ما الذي
يحدث ولكن نعم، هناك العديد من الضحايا
على طول هذه المنطقة، ربما يمكنك رؤية
حجم الضرر الذي لحق
بهذه المركبات، حيث انفجر الكثير منها
بقوة الذخيرة التي
كانوا يأخذونها وهم  الآن فقط أثناء
سحب الشاحنة الصغيرة الفعلية التي كانت
تقل مقاتلي حماس أه، واجهت
بعض المقاومة من كلايتون الحذر،
كان هناك
ثقبان من الرصاص في درع
النافذة في الزجاج الأمامي بدلاً من ذلك، لذا أوقفوا
السيارة التي خرجوا منها و  لقد
ذهبوا للتو في موجة إطلاق النار، وهذا أيضًا
يعتقدون أنه المكان الذي تم فيه أخذ الكثير من الرهائن، لقد
خرجوا للتو من هذا
وبدأوا في إمساك الناس وبدأوا في إطلاق النار على
الناس وإعادتهم إلى ذلك الجانب
من الحدود،
جون لذا كلاريسا اه سأعطيك
فرصة لالتقاط أنفاسك هنا
كنت متجهًا بالقرب من
حدود إسرائيل مع غزة أم سمعت بعض الصواريخ
يتم إطلاقها من داخل غزة ربما
بعضها، نأمل أن
يتم
اعتراضها جميعًا أم ما هو حولك فيما
يتعلق بالحياة المدنية  هل
عاد الإسرائيليون إلى
منازلهم، أليسوا هنا، ليسوا هنا، هل
تعلم أن مدينة ستوت موجودة
هناك،
وهي مدينة مزدحمة جدًا ولكن
تقريبًا كل شخص غادرها في هذه
المرحلة أو أنهم يقضون معظم
أيامهم  في ملجأ وقد أصبح هذا حقًا
نوعًا من المنطقة حيث
المركبات الوحيدة في الحياة التي تراها هي مركبات مثل
هذا
الجيش الإسرائيلي أه أفراد إسرائيليون من
الجيش الإسرائيلي يتم نقلهم ونشرهم في كل مكان على
طول هذه الحدود مما يؤجج
التكهنات بأن نوعًا ما
يمكن أن يكون الهجوم البري وشيكًا على الرغم من أن
الأمر معقد بسبب
حقيقة أن هناك الكثير من الرهائن،
أنا فقط أخرجنا من الطريق
هنا أوه،
طريق آخر، يمكنك رؤية المكان الذي أطلقوا فيه النار على
هذه السيارة هنا، لقد
دمرناها بالكامل تمامًا  لا أعلم أننا سألنا عن
عدد الأرواح التي فقدت هنا، فمن الصعب جدًا
معرفة من قد يكون على قيد الحياة
ومن تم أخذه كرهينة ولكن يمكنك
تخيل الرعب العميق بينما
كان المشهد يتكشف جون كلاريسا، هذه سارة،
دعني أسأل  أنت عنك،
لم تكن هناك فقط حيث ترى
استمرار إطلاق الصواريخ ولكنك
ذهبت بالفعل إلى الموقع الذي كان يوجد فيه
هذا المهرجان وذلك الفيديو المروع
لأشخاص يهربون للنجاة بحياتهم
ويتم ذبحهم على يد مقاتلي حماس، هل يمكنك أن
تعطينا  لدينا بعض الإحساس بما رأيته
هناك، لذا قمنا بزيارة هناك بالأمس،
سارة، سأخرج من
الطريق، هناك سيارة إسعاف قادمة من هذا الاتجاه، لقد
زرنا هناك
بالأمس ومرة ​​أخرى مجرد مذبحة، لا يزال بإمكانك
رؤية جثث أعضاء حماس
المسلحون في كل مكان يقتربون من ذلك
الكبوت حيث تجمع الآلاف من الشباب المحتفلين
للاحتفال بنهاية
الأعياد وكانوا يرقصون طوال
الليل وحتى حوالي الساعة 6:00 صباحًا
عندما بدأ المسلحون في إطلاق
وابل من الصواريخ فوق رؤوسهم ثم قاموا  لقد
تسللت بالفعل إلى حفلة الرقص،
آسف، سأنقلنا إلى
هنا مرة أخرى، فنحن نحاول الابتعاد
عن هؤلاء الأشخاص والسماح لهم بالقيام
بعملهم، وأتساءل أيضًا عما إذا كان بإمكان شخص ما في
غرفة التحكم تغيير هذا
الفيديو  لقد أظهر ذلك
اللحظات الأولى التي كنا نحتمي فيها
عندما جاء وابل الصواريخ،
لكن المشهد في ريم الذي
تتحدث عنه كان
مروعًا والخوف الذي لا يزال لدى
العديد من العائلات أنهم لا يفعلون ذلك  أعرف
سارة إذا كان أحبائهم على قيد الحياة حتى
مجموعة تطوعية إسرائيلية أه
تحدد هوية الرفات البشرية قالت أنه تم
العثور على 260 جثة على الأقل ولكن كان هناك
آلاف الأشخاص هناك
وما زالت هناك عائلات تبحث
بيأس عن أمل ولا تعرف أين
أحبائهم